this is a road in northrift Valley that
cuts through Three Counties it was
supposed to make movement in Harding
communities easier but it's a road that
is hardly used because of crime
Kenya's security forces are targeting a
62 kilometer stretch of Rolling Hills
gorges escapments and caves that are
hard to access where cattle thieves hide
out
we passed through an area called tiati
people who live here say young men use
this roads to carry out cross-boda
attacks
the community leaders in the village of
churro told Al Jazeera that they've been
stigmatized and labeled Bandits
we are afraid even to travel to other
areas people say young men from pocot my
community are aggressors they say we
have guns and that we have criminals in
our meetings but we have maintained it
we're also dealing with the same Bandits
coming to steal from us
foreign
the military and police have been
deployed to some parts
cattle rating is a historic problem in
Kenya the government has struggled to
deal with it for many years remember the
Alternatives in these areas are very
limited they're very scarce the
infrastructure is extremely wanting
they're probably some of the most
desperate parts of the country if not
for the region and so unless we
transform these communities and give
them a different system of economic
survival is going to be challenging to
root out the roots of banditry
inter-ethnic conflict has been made
worse by a mix of climate change and
politics people here will do anything to
protect their livestock animal theft is
nothing new to hurting communities but
some say the practice has been
commercialized
the government has told hundreds of
people to leave their homes in areas
where the Security operation is being
carried out
most of those who have been displaced
have moved to safer houses but they are
now living rough in crowded houses and
Open Spaces
Angeline LOL mingani says she's decided
to move here because it's near a police
camp
life is tough we have nothing we left
most of our belonging back home we have
been robbed we have no blankets we have
no Cutlery we cover ourselves with socks
at night
foreign
people who live here say they hope the
Security operation will help but they
also tell us things may not change much
Catherine soy Al Jazeera North Rift
Valley